>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
IT'S BEEN AN AMAZING 24 HOURS
EVEN BY THE ACTION-PACKED
STANDARDS OF 2018, THERE HAS
BEEN LOTS OF DRAMA AND
WASHINGTON.
AS YOU WELL KNOW, RUDY GIULIANI
REVEALED ON THE SHALE ON HANNITY
SHOW THAT PAYMENTS COHAN MADE TO
A STAR STORMY DANIELS, WHICH
SEEMED LIKE A MAJOR STORY AT THE
TIME.
BUT WITHIN HOURS IT WASN'T EVEN
THE BIGGEST STORY OF THE DAY.
NBC NEWS REPORTED THAT FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAD WIRETAPPED
COHEN'S PHONE, IT AND RECORDED A
CONVERSATION HE HAD WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
BUT THEN THAT STORY CHANGED.
THE NEW ACCOUNT REPORTS HE
SIMPLY RECORDED THE NUMBERS THAT
HE DIALED AND NOT THE CONTENT OF
THE CALLS MADE OF.
AND THAT IS WHERE WE ARE NOW, AT
8:00 P.M. EASTERN TIME.
ONE THING WE KNOW FOR SURE IS
THAT NBC SCREWED UP, BUT THAT'S
PRETTY MUCH ALL WE CAN BE
CERTAIN OF.
IF NBC'S FIRST STORY WAS WRONG,
WHY DO WE ASSUME THE SECOND WAS
RIGHT?
WE DON'T KNOW THE TRUTH AND WE
HAVE NO WAY OF KNOWING.
IN THE ABSENCE OF HONESTY FROM
OUR GOVERNMENT, WE ARE TOTALLY
DEPENDENT UPON LEAKS FOR OUR
NEWS AND MANY OF THOSE ARE
DISHONEST.
MICHAEL COHEN BY THE WAY STILL
DOESN'T KNOW WHY HIS OFFICE WAS
RATED WHY HIS PHONES AND EMAILS
WERE REPORTED TO THE GOVERNMENT.
NO ONE IN THE GOVERNMENT IS
REQUIRED TO TELL HIM NOR WILL
THEY TELL HIM.
HOW ARE WE, MEN ARRIVE AT YOUR
HOME AND SEES YOUR COMPUTERS AND
PHONES AT GUNPOINT BUT NEVER
DESCRIBE WHY THEY ARE DOING IT.
MICHAEL:        COHAN CERTAINLYS
MICHAEL:        COHAN CERTAINLYE
MICHAEL:        COHAN CERTAINLYL
MICHAEL:        COHAN CERTAINLYK
MICHAEL:        COHAN CERTAINLYE
MICHAEL:        COHAN CERTAINLYA
SHADY CHARACTER BUT SHADINESS IS
NOT A CRY.
THE FBI CAN'T DESTROY YOUR LIFE
BECAUSE YOU TALK LIKE A
CHARACTER FROM "THE SOPRANOS,"
THOSE AREN'T FELONIES.
BASIC NORMS WERE VIOLATED,
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE IS AN
ANCIENT AND VITAL CONCEPT, AND
SO IS PRIVACY.
LET'S HOPE THEY HAD A VERY GOOD
REASON FOR DOING IT.
THEY'VE BETTER HAVE GOOD
EVIDENCE THAT MICHAEL COHEN WAS
DOING SOMETHING AWFUL IN ORDER
TO JUSTIFY THIS.
IT TURNS OUT THAT ALL OF THIS
WAS ABOUT A FINANCIAL SEDIMENT
WITH SOME STAR WHICH IS BY THE
WAY A STORY THAT NOT A SINGLE
AMERICAN IS HONESTLY SHOCKED OR
THREATENED BY NO MATTER WHAT
ANDERSON COOPER TELLS YOU.
IF THAT IS ALL IT'S ABOUT THEN
WHAT WE ARE WATCHING IS A
GROTESQUE VIOLATION OF CIVIL